der machtkampf von cdu/csu ist
entschieden markus söder gibt sich
geschlagen
die würfel sind gefallen armin laschet
wird kanzlerkandidat der union sorge
dass die lage in der ukraine eskaliert
russische kriegsschiffe halten manöver
ab der westen protestiert unverständnis
und empörung das sind die reaktionen aus
der bundesliga zur geplanten super
league
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
dienstag guten abend in allen den sport
hat nachher kristin otto im blick viel
brisanz im fußball genannt
9 aufreibende tage diskussionen und
streit jetzt ist klar cdu chef armin
laschet ist der kanzlerkandidat der
union der csu vorsitzende markus söder
erklärte heute seinen verzicht
nachdem der bundesvorstand der cdu in
der nacht erst mehr als sechs stunden
lang diskutiert hatte und dann
mehrheitlich für laschet stimmte damit
ist eine der jüngeren geschichte
beispielloser machtkampf zunächst zu
ende
christiane hübscher um 12 uhr 3 zieht
markus söder zurück und erklärt damit
armin laschet zum kanzlerkandidaten der
union mein wort das ich gegeben habe
gilt ich habe ja schon angerufen und
habe ihm gratuliert habe ihm auch gesagt
dass wir jetzt das csu akzeptieren wir
haben auch die volle unterstützung
angeboten kurz daraus auftritt des
gewinners in berlin
es ist kein rauschender konfetti moment
für armin laschet zu holprig war der weg
bis hierhin markus söder hat gesagt der
bundesvorstand der cdu muss entscheiden
und in diesem bewusstsein hat der
bundesvorstand gestern ein sehr
deutliches votum getroffen laschet hatte
die geheime online-abstimmung nach
kontroverser debatte erzwungen ergebnis
31 stimmen für ihn neuen für söder sechs
enthaltungen
auch viele kritische äußerungen gegen
laschet drangen aus der cdu-zentrale
nach draußen einen ganz normalen vorgang
nennt das der kanzlerkandidat am abend
im zdf da gab es zwei gute kandidaten
und das zu einem ergebnis zu führen
loest aus dass der eine den mehr mag der
andere denen der eine dieses thema
wichtig erachtet der andere das andere
aber es ist in acht tagen entschieden
worden
nach der nacht der wahrheit für die cdu
muss nun an der großen geschlossenheit
noch gearbeitet werden so weit gehört
dass sich viele in thüringen über die
bereitschaft von markus söder als
kanzler zu kandidieren gefreut haben ich
glaube viele hätten sich eine andere
entscheidung gewünscht der
bundesvorstand hat aber eindeutig sich
für armin laschet ausgesprochen
vielleicht hat das so doch auch sein
gutes
wir noch mal eine woche darüber
diskutiert haben das ist eben nicht im
hinterzimmer alleine entschieden worden
ist wie es andere machen sondern das
einfach auch eine debatte in der partei
stattgefunden hat armin laschet muss es
nun gelingen der kandidat der ganzen
union zu werden er verspricht markus
söder eng in den wahlkampf einzubinden
bringen wir heute abend theo koll mit
dazu in berlin und am thema das war eine
denkwürdige nacht was hat denn am ende
den ausschlag für laschet gegeben
ehrliche überzeugung oder
parteidisziplin
ich glaube beides und noch mehr die
überzeugung dass armin laschet der
bessere kandidat sei trotz der
schlechten umfragewerte und auch
natürlich parteidisziplin aber
zusätzlich auch ausdrücklicher ablehnung
von markus söder es gab diejenigen die
nicht von einem csu-mann dominiert
werden wollten und es gab offensichtlich
auch eine reihe von cdu vorständen die
persönlich schlechte erfahrungen mit dem
kandidaten aus nürnberg gemacht hatten
all das kam zusammen aber die
eigentliche entscheidung ist in der
nacht davor gefallen beim treffen im
kleinen kreis mit wolfgang schäuble und
andere da wurde markus söder klar
gemacht dass laschet auf keinen fall die
kandidatur abgeben würde danach hat
söder dann das heft des handelns an den
cdu bundesvorstand übergeben und damit
letztlich auch die kandidatur
interessante einblicke und gucken ein
bisschen noch nach vorne theorie wird
dann der wahlkampf der union jetzt
ablaufen ist laschet ein kandidat von
söders gnaden sozusagen also so weit
würde ich nicht gehen aber er ist
natürlich auch abhängig von söders
unterstützung denn da geht es nicht nur
um die loyalität der csu im wahlkampf
es geht ja auch um die mobilisierung
derjenigen der cdu die sich eigentlich
markus söder gewünscht hätten und der
anfang klingt noch nicht so richtig
verheißungsvoll für armin laschet denn
die csu rief er heute prompt ihren
eigenen mann als den eigentlichen
kandidaten der herzen aus und söder
selbst beschrieb sich in der
pressekonferenz als kandidat der moderne
der jungen der zukunft also da ist noch
etwas luft nach oben in der unions
harmonie vielen dank
theo koll in berlin
insbesondere markus söder hatte immer
wieder auf die parteibasis verwiesen und
argumentiert dort habe er deutlich
größeren rückhalt als armin laschet
wie sieht jetzt heute deren reaktionen
aus stimmen von der basis
zusammengefasst von andreas weisen
sandra titel ist cdu direktkandidatin
für die landtagswahl in sachsen anhalt
anfang juni
armin laschet kanzlerkandidat sie sieht
es mit gemischten gefühlen
markus hat einfach ein bisschen mehr
ecken und kanten an ihm kann man sich
ein bisschen mehr abarbeiten kann ihnen
aber auch sage ich mal denn vielleicht
ein bisschen stärker folgen und ich
hätte mir persönlich eine
basisdemokratische entscheidung
gewünscht so wie es auch unser
landesvorsitzender sven schultze
vorgeschlagen hat beispielsweise durch
eine abstimmung bei den
kreisvorsitzenden in sachsen anhalt
hätten sie gern das experiment mit einem
bayrischen kanzlerkandidaten gewagt doch
die breiteren basis beteiligung die
landeschefs schulze gefordert hatte war
nicht durchsetzbar
das gremium was hier beschließt ist der
bundesvorstand der hat eine klare und
eindeutige aussage getroffen und jetzt
geht es mit armin laschet in die
bundestagswahl und das wird auch hier in
sachsen anderer zu sein und wir werden
ihnen nachfolgen kräften unterstützen
trotzdem nicht nur in sachsen anhalt
viele speziell im osten fremdeln mit
armin laschet war von vornherein hier in
ostdeutschland nicht der beliebteste
kandidat auch schon ich beim
parteivorsitz
nichtsdestotrotz ist es der kandidat der
union
und wir haben jetzt endlich eine
entscheidung und die entscheidung war
auch wichtig jetzt liegt es an armin
laschet er muss jetzt liefern er hat
auch die unterstützung der partei die
union steht geschlossen hinter ihm aber
er muss auch ein angebot schaffen wird
euch ja auch den fans von markus söder
die möglichkeit gibt sich weiterhin zu
engagieren
ich kann mir vorstellen dass es
schwieriger ist für vielleicht einen
thüringer am wahlkampfstand zu stellen
und für armin laschet zu werben als von
markus söder
aber genau da müssen wir uns jetzt eben
finden die nächste wahl die zum neuen
landtag sachsen-anhalts anfang juni
letzter stimmungstest vor der
bundestagswahl die union hier hofft dass
die skandale und querelen der letzten
wochen nicht zu sehr auf ihr
wahlergebnis durchschlagen
was nun herr laschet das fragen gleich
nach holz bettina schausten und peter
frey hier im zdf und ein porträt des
kanzlerkandidaten der union finden sie
bei uns in der zdf- heute- app unser
nächstes thema heute haben die korona
anlage zunächst die beim impfen
da hat die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde grünes licht gegeben
der impfstoff von johnson & johnson darf
uneingeschränkt verwendet werden in sehr
seltenen fällen könne er jedoch
blutgerinnsel auslösen
in deutschland haben mittlerweile mehr
als 20 prozent der menschen eine impfung
bekommen
das robert koch institut registrierte
9600 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind rund 1200 weniger als
vergangene woche
297 todesfälle kamen hinzu
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
sank auf 162,4 zu den maßnahmen die die
zahlen wieder nach unten treiben sollen
gehören auch die freiwilligen corona
tests am arbeitsplatz ab heute gilt der
arbeitgeber muss allen die nicht im home
office arbeiten mindestens einen test in
der woche kostenlos zur verfügung
stellen
bei viel kundenkontakt oder wenn
arbeitnehmer in
gemeinschaftsunterkünften wohnen sind es
zwei tests in der woche bildungslücken
und psychische probleme kinder und
jugendliche werden an den auswirkungen
der pandemie wohl noch lange knabbern
um für sie die negativen folgen der
korona krise auszugleichen stellt
bundesfamilienministerin franziska
giffey 2 milliarden euro bereit wie
dringend nötig ein aufholprozess ist
zeigt eine studie des ifo instituts zu
homeschooling und distanz unterricht
markus kraus jetzt mit den ergebnissen
die zwölfte klasse des bertha von
suttner gymnasiums steht kurz vor dem
abitur letzten monat waren sie noch im
wechsel unterricht eine woche zu hause
eine woche schule schule und corona
keine leichte zeit für sie
am anfang waren alle überfordert das war
natürlich eine neue situation also ich
gehe auch alles sehr schnell für die
lehrer an ja auch für die schüler
kommunikation ist immer schwierig sei es
zwischen schüler lehrer oder allgemein
auch zwischen schüler und schüler nach
aussagen der befragten eltern haben die
schüler rund 4,3 stunden am tag mit
schulischen tätigkeiten verbracht das
sind rund drei stunden weniger als an
einem schultag vor corinna um so mehr
zeit haben sie vor dem fernseher dem
computer oder dem handy gesessen
im durchschnitt waren es 4,6 stunden pro
stunde
das sagen 56 prozent der eltern lernen
die kinder zu hause doch weniger als in
der schule
bei der mehrheit der kinder und
jugendliche ist es so dass natürlich das
lernen zu hause sehr stark leidet
besonders leistungsschwache schüler
können zu hause so die studie deutlich
weniger effektiv und konzentriert lernen
es gibt immer noch zu wenig gemeinsam
video unterricht für die klassen so die
kritik das digitale klassenzimmer liegt
immer noch in weiter ferne
insgesamt ist das schon eher ernüchternd
was wir sehen das gibt schon schulen
haben sich auf den weg gemacht und
machen jetzt viel mehr
es gibt aber auch sehr viele wo das
nicht der fall ist und wo auch gerade zu
hause das lernen nicht so gut klappt um
das zu verbessern müsse die politik
klare vorgaben für einen
flächendeckenden online unterricht
liefern andauernde schulschließungen
könnten wissenslücken weiter vergrößern
eine drängende frage für die forscher
wie unsere impfstoffe auch gegen die
mutationen des virus wirken eine neue
mutation gleich eine doppelte macht
schlagzeilen sie soll für die massive
welle von infektionen in indien
verantwortlich sein
und sie ist auch in europa bereits
festgestellt worden anselm stern klärt
auf lange schlangen am bahnhof sie
wollen noch schnell raus etwa aus mumbai
oder neu delhi
bevor hier strenge ausgangssperren in
kraft treten
indien meldet fast 260.000 neue corona
fälle an einem tag schlechte virus
zahlen möglicherweise auch wegen der
neuen virus variante b 16 17 eine
variante die auch experten in
deutschland verfolgen
eine variante sich auch in europa
durchsetzen könnte insbesondere selbst
dort wo es die britische mutation b 11 7
schon gibt das heißt dass wir auch für
uns sehr besorgniserregend wenn sich
diese variante in deutschland verbreiten
würde
bislang gibt es in deutschland nur sehr
vereinzelte fälle acht seien es im
ganzen land so das robert-koch-institut
dass die indische variante aktuell auf
der beobachtungsliste führt klar sei b
16 17 habe zwei mutationen an der
virusoberfläche die unter anderem die
wirkung von impfstoffen etwas
abschwächen könnten
beide sitzen in diesem sogenannten spike
protein also dem oberflächenprotein
gegen das eben auch die antikörper
gerichtet sind und beide dieser stellen
kennt man eben schon im anderen
zusammenhang mit einer davon ist immer
beteiligt eigentlich wenn es darum geht
dass diese varianten so ein bisschen die
immunabwehr absprechen die wirkung von
antikörpern wird dadurch abgeschreckt
hier denke ich kann man auch damit
rechnen dass die impfstoffe vielleicht
ein bisschen weniger wirken aber dass
sie gar nicht mehr wirken damit rechnen
wir eigentlich nicht mit mehr fällen der
indischen variante rechnet wohl
großbritannien 77 gibt es hier aktuell
für einreisende aus indien gelten wegen
der virus lage dort jetzt neue strenge
regeln und so fiel zunächst in dieser
sendung zum thema corona jetzt ins
ausland der konflikt zwischen russland
und der ukraine spitzt sich weiter zu
und gleich mehrere westliche staaten
machen moskau für die eskalation
verantwortlich
denn russland hat inzwischen
zehntausende soldaten an die grenze zur
ukraine verlegt kriegsschiff verhalten
manöver im schwarzen meer ab die
menschen in der ukraine fürchten einen
neuen krieg im zentrum stehen gebiete in
der ost ukraine die von moskau treuen
separatisten kontrolliert werden lohans
und donetsk von dort berichtet katrin
eigendorf
die stellung der ukrainischen armee
droht im schlamm zu versinken
es regnet seit stunden die soldaten
nehmen unser team mit durch den
schützengraben wir sind direkt an der
frontlinie eines neu eskalierenden
konflikte auf der anderen seite ist es
still
doch das kann sich schnell ändern sagt
rolle die mir aber wenn sie schießen wir
schießen nicht zurück nicht provozieren
lassen lautet der befehl aus kiew eine
eskalation vermeiden und über steuern
sie lassen ständig drohnen fliegen sie
provozieren uns demonstrativ und gezielt
auf kleinem niveau und versuchen uns in
einen konflikt hineinzuziehen dass wir
beginnen ihre seite zu erschießen
das ukrainische verteidigungsministerium
zeigt in einem video bilder die die
verlegung russischer truppen an die
ostgrenze dokumentieren sollen 40.000
soldaten was ist russlands weiteres ziel
das fragen sich auch die ukrainischen
soldaten hier direkt an der frontlinie
der ost ukraine herrscht bei den
ukrainischen streitkräften ratlosigkeit
was russland zurzeit wirklich bezweckt
doch sie sind auf alles vorbereitet
provokationen aber auch einen weiteren
krieg die ukrainische armee das wissen
sie hier kann einen krieg gegen russland
nicht gewinnen nicht einmal wirklich
führen die einzige perspektive ist auf
internationale unterstützung zu setzen
und darauf dass europäer und amerikaner
druck ausüben auf russland die pandemie
hat weltweit viele auswirkungen auch auf
die pressefreiheit etwa wenn
journalisten bei demonstrationen
angegriffen werden
deutschland ist deswegen in der
alljährlichen rangliste der organisation
reporter ohne grenzen vom elften auf den
13 platz abgerutscht
ganz vorn wie gehabt die skandinavischen
länder deutlich weiter hinten liegt
tschechien auf platz 40
britta hilpert jetzt mit den gründen 19
uhr zeit für die nachrichten auch in
prag
keine medium vertrauen tschechen mehr
als dem öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
doch seine unabhängigkeit ist in gefahr
generaldirektor catwalk fürchtet um
seinen job
die politik einfluss gewinnen über
personal und inhalte sagt er
denn im herbst wird gewinnen das ist ein
kampf zwischen den demokratischen
idealen sie die wir als öffentlich
rechtlicher sender stehen und einigen
politischen kräften die fürchten nach
den wahlen nicht mehr an der macht
zusammen
vor dem sender demonstrierten sie für
die pressefreiheit nicht zum ersten mal
seit anja busch und milos zeman
tschechien für staatspräsident seemann
widmet schon mal eine kalaschnikow der
presse und sein regierungschef fabisch
ist nicht nur politiker sondern auch
medien mogul beherrscht inzwischen 30
prozent der privaten medien zu berichten
entsprechend positiv über ihn
die unabhängige berichterstattung des
rundfunks mit zuletzt über schlechtes
pandemie management über weltweit
höchsten infektionsraten nimmt der
regierungschef persönlich journalisten
hassten ihn beklagte auf eigen und
kanälen
sie berichten nichts positives seit er
im amt ist verlor tschechien bereits 17
plätze im pressefreiheit ranking es ist
sehr ernst die tschechische regierung
möchte den öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk politisieren und möchte die
unabhängigkeit untergraben und aushöhlen
sollte das erfolg haben könnte
tschechien im ranking weiter abrutschen
bei der europäischen
weltraumorganisation esa ging es heute
um ein thema das über unseren köpfen
mehr und mehr zur gefahr wird um schrott
im weltraum mehr als 100 millionen teile
sind dort oben unterwegs viele schneller
als pistolenkugeln bei einem
zusammenprall können sie satelliten
zerstören und jedes mal entsteht neuer
weltraumschrott es wird immer enger in
der umlaufbahn ein ziel der esa ab 2025
schrott aus dem weltraum zu entsorgen
angreifer im all gerade haben wir ihn
kurz gesehen soll weltraumschrott
einsammeln und ihn dann
mit ihm und soll dann mit ihm in der
atmosphäre verglühen kostet etwa 100
millionen euro
beim geld machst du weiter nicht ganz
wir haben zwar immer fußball englische
woche in der bundesliga fünf spieltage
vor saisonende geht es neben dem kampf
um die internationalen plätze vor allem
auch um schalke 04 bei einer niederlage
in bielefeld stünde der vierte abstieg
der königsblauen heute abend fest es
wird ein schwerer gang nach bielefeld
nach nur zwei saisonsiegen und fünf
verschiedenen trainern aufgeben gilt
aber immer noch nicht ich möchte nicht
verlieren und das ist auch unser
hauptaugenmerk jetzt gegen arminia
bielefeld und alles was danach kommt
szenarien und so weiter
damit beschäftige ich richtig bielefeld
steht als fünfzehnter viel besser da
braucht aber dringend punkte der letzte
schalker sieg ist ihnen eine warnung wir
fragen mal kurz beim fc augsburg nach
wie vor am vorletzten spieltag gegen
schalke gespielt haben gewinnt bielefeld
daheim erlebt schalker ein trauriges
jubiläum 40 jahre nach dem ersten
bundesliga abstieg im juni 1981 wird es
wieder heißen und zeige ich damit
abgestiegen
bayerns vorstandschef karl heinz
rummenigge hat sich kurzfristig ins
exekutivkomitee der uefa wählen lassen
und prompt als vertreter der
europäischen klub-vereinigung das klare
nein des deutschen rekordmeisters super
league bekräftigt bayern gegen dortmund
vielleicht schon bald in der super
league die gestrigen presseerklärung
beider deutscher giganten eher schwammig
als wollten sich die klub bosse noch ein
hintertürchen zur großen
gelddruckmaschine offenhalten beim
seinen aktionären verpflichteten bvb
tauchten die verantwortlichen heute ab
ein klares bekenntnis dagegen von
rummenigge
ich darf im namen des vorstandes
ausdrücklich feststellen dass der fc
bayern nicht an der super league
teilnimmt der fc bayern steht
solidarisch zur bundesliga
demonstrationen wie in liverpool dürften
den bayern somit erspart bleiben deren
gut wurde heute noch durch äußerungen
von real madrids präsidenten
angestachelt einem den großen
strippenzieher koloss mit den geldern
der champions league so wie sie jetzt
sind sterben wir es gibt immer weniger
zuschauer und weniger geld wir werden
alle sterben und bin ich als auch das
zitat von von herrn perez höre dass er
ihm sagt das ist alternativlos weil 2024
wird es wegen co ohne die ganzen
vereinen nicht mehr geben
dann weiß ich nicht ob das der klub der
superreichen ist sondern eher der club
de super verschuldeten ist tatsächlich
haben die deutschen topclubs deutlich
besser gewirtschaftet
ging es doch nur ums geld ja ich würde
es wieder tun und was sie auch weiß es
ganz sicher jetzt geht es ums wetter
morgen schauer und gewitter alle details
gleich von posten terry was nun herr
laschet wie schon mal angekündigt jetzt
gleich nach uns und dann um 21 45 hat
der kollege claus kleber das heute
journal
und wir sehen uns gerne morgen wieder
für heute danke dass sie dabei waren in
allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]